Our Law and justice lead.
As attorneys
for former President Donald Trump
brace for more possible indictments,
the Trump campaign is hitting back
with a new
ad that is,
as you might expect, a bit over the top
Like a pack of rabid wolves, they attack.
So let's impeach him.
Let's get tainted.
Radical left prosecutors to charge him
Hmm. Interesting.
CNN's Christine Holmes is here
with more on the ad.
But let's start
with one of the prosecutors
that we saw in that clip.
We're going to start with CNN's
Caitlin Plant,
who's in Florida,
where a grand jury
and special counsel Jack
Smith's investigation
heard testimony
from a former Trump spokesman today.
Actually, we're going to go to Kristen
Holmes first,
because we're having some issues there.
Christine, tell us more about this ad
and actually, let me start.
Let me play a little bit more attention,
play a little more another excerpt
of the ad
Here's a question for you.
Just how far are the radical left
and inside the beltway bandits
willing to go to stop We all know
they hate him
for winning the fight to protect life,
for exposing their deep state,
for draining their precious swamp
And they already know he'll crush Biden
so much there to fact-check and dispute.
But what are they trying to accomplish
with that?
Well, in this ad,
it's the first time
we actually see them
using these images of Jack Smith,
who was the special counsel.
And it really seems to serve
as a preemptive strike.
And I have been told by sources
close to Trump that he has been,
as he does
crowdsource saying opinions
on whether or not he's
going to be indicted.
I have been told by Trump advisers
that they are bracing for an indictment,
one specifically saying
that they believe
he will be indicted in this
and this is the defense
that we are likely to see.
They are not just calling it
political and a witch hunt and a hoax
this time.
They are also calling it
election interference.
And that was something that I was told
by these Trump officials.
They were going to be going
to the Department of Justice
to talk about the fact
that this could be construed
as electrode interference
as he runs for his third
presidential term.
And one thing I do want to point out here
is that it's not just Trump
that they're worried
about being indicted.
We are also told
that members of the team
are very concerned
that a low level staffer
as well as a maintenance worker at Mar
a Lago, are going to be indicted
in this documents case.
We know this
because witnesses
have been asked
about both of these
individuals, their role at Mar a Lago,
and they were seen on tape
moving the boxes at one point.
And so, again,
this is a team right now
that is bracing for yet
another series of indictments in yet
another battle
that Trump has as he is trying to win
the GOP nomination. Okay, interesting.
Comms are now back up with CNN's
Caleb Plant is in Florida
where a grand jury in special counsel
Jackson's investigation
heard from a former Trump
spokesman today Kelly. Tell us about that
Well, Jake, they heard from a spokesman
who just wasn't working
for Donald Trump in his political empire,
but was one of the people
who was around the former president
at a very crucial moment.
In February of 20, 22,
Donald Trump had sent back
15 boxes of documents
to the National Archives.
The Archives
found records with classified markings
in them
kicking off
this criminal investigation
that we are so closely
tracking right now.
And at that moment, Donald Trump
wanted to put out a statement
saying that he had turned over everything
and there were people around him
who somehow made that statement
not happen.
And they were warning him
that he should be consulting
with his attorney.
One of those people was Taylor Berkowitz,
this person who is a close aide to him
and was his spokesperson,
now works for MAGA
Inc, a super PAC, and Taylor Branch,
which did come
to the federal courthouse here
today, this morning.
We have learned through our reporting
that he testified to the grand jury
a little under an hour,
and he released a statement
not disclosing
exactly what he was asked about
or the extent of questioning
or any indication
he might have of where
this investigation is right now.
But he said
that he fulfilled a legal obligation
to testify in front of a grand jury.
And I answered every question honestly.
We're still waiting to see exactly
what that means for the investigation
and what might still be to come Jake.
All right.
Caleb Plants and Kristen
Holmes, thanks to both of you.
Appreciate it.
Joining us now to discuss
much, much more than just that Republican
presidential candidate
and former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie.
It's a New Jersey day here on this,
the lead.
So let's just start with the news
that was just reported.
It does appear that Donald Trump is
likely to be if not he's likely to be,
then he's at least preparing
to be indicted
by special counsel
Jack Smith
in this classified documents case.
What's your reaction
Well, look,
I think that
one of the biggest indications
is this most recent meeting
earlier in the week
that his attorneys
had with Jack Smith and people at DOJ.
You're a former U.S. attorney.
So, you know,
when a meeting like that would be
my guess is that
he probably got a target letter
where at the very end of an investigation
you typically go to the target
to give them an opportunity
to come in to the grand jury themselves.
If they want to testify,
they almost never agree to do that.
But usually an outgrowth of that is for
you know, the lawyers to say,
but we'd like to come in and argue to you
why the case shouldn't be brought.
My guess is that
that's probably much
of what happened on Monday.
So it shows you you're at the near end,
not at the absolute end,
but nearly at the end of this portion
of the investigation.
I suspect
you've already said that
Donald Trump has disqualified himself
to be president again.
Do you think this is more
fuel to the fire?
Well, sure.
As I said, you know, a number of times
being under indictment
is not good for a political candidate.
And the fact is that with this one,
we'll see what
the evidence turns out to be.
But some of the reporting
that I've read
leads you to conclude that they have
some very substantial evidence
about his state of mind.
And that's always
one of the difficult things
when you're prosecuting
one of these cases.
Meaning he knew what he was doing
was wrong
and was afoul of the rules,
and he knew that he.
It sounds like
they have evidence that he knew
he had classified documents
and that he wasn't
permitted to show them to people.
Well, that undercuts
the argument
he's made,
that everything was declassified
as soon as he walked out the door
because he said so.
So there's some things there
that are kind of interesting
and we'll see.
You know,
I never like to make evaluations
on this stuff.
Having done it for seven years,
to actually see the indictment
and see what they have.
But certainly
if you're the president,
the former president
and his lawyers right now,
you're not going to be very happy
about what's developing.
I've had Republican former
Justice Department officials
say to me that this is much worse
than what Hillary Clinton did.
And the theme of Donald Trump's
convention in 2016 was lock her up.
You did
you prosecuted her from
the from the stage
there about all the things that allegedly
she did wrong This is worse.
Look,
you know, the classified documents
that that he had that we now know he had
were things that should have
never left the White House
And if he in fact, knew
that he had these
documents, was looking at them,
utilizing them in some way
after he left office.
And it looks like maybe even two years
after he left office, it's a big problem.
So you're running for president.
You just declared last night.
You're joining
what's a pretty crowded
field, surprisingly,
considering
there's a former president in it as well.
Now, right now, you're polling in the low
single digits.
I know
you haven't even been in the race
for a day,
but in 2016,
you ran you placed 10th in Iowa,
six in New Hampshire
for getting out of the race.
What is going to make this year
different?
Well,
the whole atmosphere is different, Jake.
You know, in
20, 15 and 16 when we ran the first time,
you had a situation where Donald Trump
had no record to speak of.
He had been on a TV show.
I have been a developer,
private developer in New York.
There was no way
to really make the case against him.
And we
I think all of us myself,
Jeb Bush,
Marco Rubio, John Kasich, Ted Cruz
all found it very difficult
to make the case
because he could say
whatever he wanted to say.
There is no proof point
to prove that he couldn't do it.
So I'm going to build a wall
across the entire border of Mexico.
Mexico's going to pay for it.
Well, I don't think he's
going to be able to do that.
Physically figure out a way to do it.
But how can you prove that he wouldn't?
This is different today.
We know he said he would build a wall
across the entire border, Mexico.
He didn't do it.
About a quarter of the wall was built.
He said Mexico would pay for it.
We haven't gotten our first peso
and we know a lot of other things.
So he was going to repeal
and replace Obamacare.
He had a Republican Congress
for two years, didn't get it done.
Said he was going to balance the budget
in four years,
left with the greatest deficit
of any president in modern history.
Said he was going to
get rid of the national debt
in eight years.
And left it trillions
higher than when he walked in the door
in just four years.
There is a record here, Jake,
on things, both very,
very significant on public policy.
But even on the trivial.
Remember,
he used to go after Barack Obama
for playing golf.
And I remember
standing on the debate stage one time.
He looked in the camera and said,
I will not play golf a day
because I'll be so busy
fixing all of America's problems.
And he wanted to play golf for 260 days.
So problems promises both big and small.
He broke them.
He disappointed our party.
He disappointed the country.
And that's going to be
the focus of this campaign.
I have a lot more to ask you about.
Are going to have to.